hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun problem
solve 615 plus x squared is equal to 2
to the power of y over the integers
you're not allowed to use computers or
calculators
i thank luca kisambarelli from georgia
for suggesting this problem and for
sending a solution
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this equation
well i'll admit that i did not solve
this problem
so i resorted to wolfram alpha
you can solve equations for integer
solutions
for example if you type solve 3x plus 4y
is equal to 5 over the integers wolfram
alpha will give you examples of integer
solutions
so i thought
since i'm not able to solve this problem
maybe i can get the result from wolfram
alpha
so i typed it in and to my great
surprise it said the result is false
the examples of integer solutions it
gave were not actual solutions to this
equation over the integers
so this is wrong the problem actually
does have a solution
so now let's proceed to solve a problem
that wolfram alpha is not yet able to
solve
how can we do that
we'll start with the basic observation
since x squared is non-negative
2 to the power of y is at least six
hundred and fifteen
we can then conclude y is greater than
nine because two to the power of nine is
equal to five hundred and twelve
we then proceed by considering that if
this equation has a solution
both sides need to have the same last
digit
so we'll analyze the very last digit of
615 plus x squared
we'll start out by considering x the
very last digit it could have is from
zero to nine
so then we consider the last digit of x
squared
we take the square of each of these
digits and consider only the last digit
to get the last digit of 615 plus x
squared we add 5 to each of the last
digits of x squared
we now consider the very last digit of 2
to the power of y
you can figure this out by doing a few
calculations if you calculate the values
for y is equal to 1 2 3 4 and so on
you'll see a pattern the last digit of 2
to the power of y
will follow a pattern 2 four eight six
then the pattern will repeat two four
eight six
and so on for every four numbers
now in order that the last digits match
we look at the last digit of 6 15 plus x
squared and we want to see which ones
correspond to 2 4 8 or 6.
this only happens when x is equal to 1 3
7 or 9
and the last digit will be six or four
so for the digits to match the very last
digits
x would have to be one three seven or
nine
and y would have to be two four 6 8 and
so on in other words y would have to be
an even number so we've established that
y is even and that'll be the key to
solving this problem
why does this help us
well if y is even that means y is equal
to 2 times n
for n an integer
we can then substitute 2 to the n for y
so we have 615 plus x squared is equal
to 2 to the power of 2n
we then subtract x squared from both
sides
and now we use a clever trick
on the right hand side we have a
difference of squares
so we can use the difference of squares
formula that a squared minus b squared
is equal to the quantity a plus b times
the quantity a minus b
in this case we can factor that 615 is
equal to the quantity 2 to the n plus x
times 2 to the n minus x
so
we're now going to analyze 615
for two factors 2 to the n plus x and 2
to the n minus x
we can do this by considering the prime
factorization
615 is equal to 3 times 5 times 41.
so we consider which two numbers what
pairs of factors we could have which
would equal 615
we can enumerate the possibilities
we can have 1 times 615 we can have 3
times 205
5 times 123
or 15 times 41
now how can we figure out which
possibility corresponds to our solution
well consider adding the two factors
together to the n plus x plus 2 to the n
minus x will equal two times two to the
n
and that simplifies to be two to the
power of n plus one
so the sum of the two factors is equal
to two to the power of n plus one
so we now consider the sum of the
factors in each of these four cases
we need it to be a power of two
and of these four numbers only 128
is a power of two
so the sum of factors if there's a
solution would be 128 which equals 2 to
the power of 7 which equals 2 to the
power of n plus 1.
therefore n is equal to 6 and then y is
equal to 2 times n which is 12.
now with this knowledge how can we solve
for x
well we can consider the difference of
factors
2 to the n plus x minus the quantity 2
to the n minus x is equal to 2x and
that's the difference of the two factors
so now we take the difference of 123 and
5 and we get 118.
that's equal to 2x which means x is
equal to 59. so if there's a solution it
would have to be
x is equal to 59 and y is equal to 12.
and in fact we can verify that 615 plus
59 squared is equal to 4096 which
exactly equals 2 to the power of 12.
and for completeness we should also
include x is equal to negative 59 and y
is equal to 12 because integers can be
both positive and negative
and i'll admit this was a solution i
overlooked when i first published this
video thank you all for catching the
mistake
we just solved a problem that wolfram
alpha is not yet able to solve
and all we did was use the principles of
number theories
i think that's pretty neat
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos which can be watched
for free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos
watch and share all of the videos on
mind your decisions
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
books which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support